how's your life going uh you know what
the the sex life may I ask you intrude I
mean this is something that you're
always very open about and I don't get
to ask anyone else that you know you
could not employees because that's
called harassment I learned that the
hard way I'd say oh so you'd like to
work here at Team Coco would you well
first question how's your sex life and
then I find out from these quote lawyers
that I'm in the wrong anyway I learned
my lesson uh my sex life is pretty good
uh she'd be having it it'd be good she'd
be getting them titties honked that's
nice
um wait you like having them honked yeah
wait a minute I'm just sorry that would
doesn't sound like
if things are heating up if things are
heating up and the guy's like
I would think he would go south yeah no
they're dancing around the room here
uh I was once going down on a man and I
was like give me that dick and he was
like Nicole you can't do that anymore I
will not have sex with you anymore if
you do that so I like fun times other
people don't oh wait he didn't like that
you said in a sort of a fun I'm gonna
sucker
no one wants to oral sex from Cookie
Monster
cookies cookie crumbs just go flying
along with other things and so that's no
no one I could see the guy being a
little thrown off by that are you doing
a lot of voices and shtick when you're
well not anymore because people don't
enjoy it well I don't know you might
okay
I'm just saying
I mean am I allowed to speak freely here
no I think I think I if if just just
saying hypothetical if you or I were
engaged in something like that that's
your brand and I would be honored to
have that you know what I'm saying oh
wow okay are you hitting on me no I mean
I appreciate that but well maybe I don't
know maybe I mean come on that would be
that would be a magical and erotic treat
through the wonderlands of Nicole
buyer's sex life I know but first of all
um back off yes
do I need lawyers you do and you need a
lot of lawyers man I do apologize
but I think what you're saying is uh is
is valid I know you and I know that if
someone was uh if your lover was uh
engaged and in an act with you and
suddenly started to impersonate one of
the Watergate burglars
you would love it I'd probably finish
right there yeah yeah you're constantly
constantly closing your eyes and
pretending it's halderman and
ehrlichmann that flat top yeah oh boy uh
freak uh anyway
the current situation all is well have
you found someone who uh appreciates
your sense of humor in sensual moments
or is it just across the board you're
not allowed to do that it's like across
the board most of the people I've hooked
up with are like please don't do that
yeah there's got to be someone that
appreciates that that's that's who you
are I think this is right is this
Winston again I think it might be maybe
oh must be for people but maybe they
don't want like a performance like they
want just me which is
just kind of quieter no I scream a lot
at home uh I don't know Less on I guess
like I'm loud but I'm not like
necessarily performing so maybe people
want like real connections or something
I have to say it's not even what you're
saying but uh if I heard give me that
dick I might try I might run away really
because I think someone wants to take it
from me oh that's what it sounds like
you know I it sounds like it's gonna
leave my body and go with them and I'd
be afraid well no I don't want to take
it well here's the thing if in the wild
if uh if you encounter a creature and
they say the worst thing you can do is
run uh but if you get scared that's the
natural reaction if I heard give me that
dick I would start to run that's just
what I would do oh in life whenever I've
heard give me that dick I run
what you're usually hearing is give me
that comma dick meaning like give me
that pen dick oh no it work that's
constantly I'm running yeah and I forgot
I didn't I didn't hear the comma I
didn't hear the pause yeah and how do
you meet people can I ask that oh apps I
well it would be nice to meet someone in
person but I'm on Tinder Raya Okay Cupid
Bumble uh hinge there was a thing it was
like a fat lady app and I can't remember
I think it's called like woo plus
um and I'm sure oh coffee meets bagel
I think there's another one but yeah
eight apps I can't can I say something I
can't list this number of anything
I can't I can't name that number of
anything in the universe and you just
tore through those I've been on them for
a long time it's been a long time
okay so you go on these and I this is
I'm a complete stranger in this world I
I have been married for a long time I
was never on an app so I don't
understand it I don't understand how it
works do you then go meet these people
in a neutral area yeah well I mean it
depends what do you like if you're
trying to you go to like a place
with a bed like a home or if you're
trying to connect you go to like a bar
or dinner you meet them in public and
it's made clear when you respond which
of those two it is yeah so I'm like a
police officer by the way questioning
trying to figure out no I just want to
know I don't know how it all works I
don't know anything about that so
usually some I like when people message
me first so they'll say something like
hey cutie and I'm like hi
um I'm never excited to answer anybody
um and then lately because I'm older now
so now I'm like horny For Love or
whatever I'm like I want love I think
I've you know a dick is a dick it just
has to be attached to someone nice and
now
um
to be nice to me
um I'm not looking to hook up anymore so
you have to like ask me on a date I
don't know how I would do if I Were
Somehow single now and on apps I don't
think you would have to get on an app
did you know you're famous so like
people would find somebody for you
they'd be like Conan who are these
people your friends you do have friends
same for you two you're famous now right
I'm mildly successful yeah I bet you
could just have your pick of the litter
no you'd be surprised I am surprised
sometimes there are men who are
intimidated by a successful woman
because in that that shouldn't be the
case but I'm sure that is and you are
quite successful you do very well you're
you're bringing in the Bucks and then
you meet some guy and he works at Jiffy
Lube and uh he's intimidated yeah but he
shouldn't be because he could change the
oil in my Jeep
oh we could do it together that's nice
you have a Jeep okay yeah so if you see
me don't wave no I'm kidding you can
wave
I got
an interactive car because it has a Jeep
wave you go Boop
if you see other people in another Jeep
in another Jeep you're supposed to give
them the V sign yeah you drive and you
go
and nobody ever does it back to me and
it makes me so sad people in Tesla's
give each other the finger yeah because
they know they know the other guys an
too